Sommes nous seuls dans l’Univers?
Difficile de ne pas se poser la question,
quand on a la chance d’observer
un ciel constellé d’étoiles
par une belle nuit d’été.
Parmi ces milliers d’étoiles, quand même,
il doit bien y en avoir au moins UNE
autour de laquelle on a une planète
comme la nôtre, qui abrite la vie.
D’autant que quand je parle
de « milliers d’étoiles »,
je suis très très très très en-dessous de
la réalité.
Les étoiles visibles à l’œil nu ne sont
qu’une infime fraction
de celle qu’on trouve dans l’Univers.
Faisons un calcul rapide.
Si on pouvait regarder notre galaxie,
la Voie lactée,
de l’extérieur, elle ressemblerait
en gros à ça.
Et nous on est là.
Le diamètre de notre galaxie est d’environ
100 000 années lumières,
et elle contiendrait en tout entre
100 et 400 milliards d’étoiles,
on ne sait pas exactement.
Donc c’est vraiment beaucoup plus
que les quelques milliers d’étoiles
qu’on voit à l’œil nu
Et ça c’est juste pour la Voile Lactée,
mais des galaxies, il y en a d’autres.
Par exemple la Galaxie d’Andromède,
notre plus proche voisine,
qui est située à 2,5 millions
d’années lumière,
et qui contiendrait jusqu’à
1000 milliards d’étoiles.
OK, et des galaxies comme ça, on en trouve
combien dans l’Univers?
Eh bien on peut faire une estimation.
Regardez cette image, elle a été prise
par le télescope spatial Hubble,
en visant un coin bien sombre du ciel
dans la constellation du Fourneau,
c’est dans l’hémisphère Sud.
Rien que dans cette image, on peut dénombrer
environ 10 000 galaxies.
Et ça ne correspond qu’à un coin minuscule.
La surface du ciel couverte
par cette photo,
c’est en gros celle de la pointe d’une mine
de crayon tenue à bout de bras.
Si on voulait capturer l’ensemble du ciel
avec des photos de ce genre,
il faudrait 25 millions d’images
comme celle-ci.
Evidemment on va pas le faire,
mais si on imagine
que chacune de ces images contienne
en moyenne 10 000 galaxies,
ça nous fait une estimation 250 milliards
de galaxies dans l’Univers observable.
Si chacune des 250 milliards de galaxies
contient en moyenne 400 milliards d’étoiles,
faites la multiplication: ça nous fait
100 000 milliards de milliards d’étoiles,
une quantité invraisemblable.
On peut discuter les ordre de grandeur,
mais ce qu’on dit souvent,
c’est que 100 000 milliards de milliards
c’est en gros comparable
au nombre de grains de sable
qu’il y a sur Terre.
Or depuis maintenant plus de 25 ans,
on sait détecter des planètes
autour d’étoiles autres que la nôtre,
des exoplanètes,
et on a de bonne raison de penser
que la présence de planètes
autour des étoiles est un phénomène
relativement commun.
Pour faire simple, on va retenir l’estimation
d’une planète en moyenne par étoile,
et ça nous fait donc au total dans l’Univers
100 000 milliards de milliards de planètes.
C’est inimaginable.
A part le nombre de grains de sable sur Terre,
une autre manière de se le représenter
c’est de dire que si on s’amusait à
se partager les planètes de l’Univers
entre tous les humains, chacun de nous
en recevrait plus de10 000 milliards.
Pas de problème de voisinage!
Alors OK, on sait très bien que toutes
ces planètes
ne sont pas propices au développement
de la vie.
Mais quand même, même si c’est une
sur 1 milliards,
ça fait quand même une quantité
monstrueuse.
L’Univers devrait grouiller
d’extraterrestres.
Sauf qu’on en a jamais vu aucun.
Ce petit calcul, et l’interrogation
métaphysique qui va avec,
c’est ce qu’on appelle le paradoxe de Fermi,
en référence au physicien Enrico Fermi qui,
après avoir fait le calcul,
s’était exclamé de façon fameuse:
mais où est-ce qu’ils sont tous?
Et la première manière assez naturelle
de résoudre ce paradoxe,
c’est de se dire: ils sont loin… très loin.
Vous le savez, dès qu’on parle de voyage
interstellaire voire intergalactique,
on a tout de suite un gros problème:
la vitesse de la lumière.
D’après notre compréhension actuelle
de la physique,
il n’est pas possible de la dépasser.
Et donc même si on savait atteindre
disons 1/5e de cette vitesse,
il nous faudrait 20 ans pour rejoindre
l’étoile la plus proche de nous,
Proxima du Centaure, qui est située
à 4 années lumières.
Pour fixer les idées, le truc le plus
lointain qu’on ait jamais créé,
c’est la sonde Voyager 1:
elle a été lancée en 1977
et se trouve actuellement à 22 milliards
de kilomètres de nous,
même pas 1 millième de la distance
qui nous sépare de Proxima.
Donc même en allant beaucoup plus vite,
on n’est a priori pas près d’atteindre
une autre étoile.
Je ne parle même pas d’une autre galaxie.
Bon donc voilà, c’est plié en fait,
il y a peut-être des extraterrestres,
mais on ne les atteindra jamais,
et réciproquement.
On est tous trop loin les uns des autres…
eh ben en fait non, pas forcément!
On estime l’âge de l’Univers à 13,8
milliards d’années.
Le système solaire, et donc la Terre, eux,
n’ont que 4,5 milliards d’années,
et là-dedans notre espèce quelques
centaines de milliers d’années.
Imaginons une autre planète, autour
d’une autre étoile.
Elle a pu se former presque n’importe
quand dans le passé.
Même dans la Voie lactée, il y en a plein
qui ont actuellement 6, 8
ou 10 milliards d’années.
Ca veut dire que si une civilisation
intelligente est apparue sur cette planète,
elle a très bien pu le faire il y a disons
deux milliards d’années.
En deux milliards d’années d’existence,
une civilisation aurait largement
eu le temps de coloniser la Voie lactée.
On l’a dit, notre galaxie fait environ
100 000 années lumière de diamètre,
donc même à 20% de la vitesse de la lumière,
en juste 500 000 ans on peut la traverser.
Alors évidemment, qui voudrait faire un
trajet sans escale de 500 000 ans?
Personne, à l’échelle d’une vie humaine
en tout cas.
Mais si on imagine un développement par
colonisation successive, ça irait assez vite.
Sur cette représentation, chaque pixel
fait à peu près 100 années lumières.
Imaginez qu’une civilisation démarre ici,
puis envoie des vaisseaux sur des planètes
situées dans chacun des pixels adjacents.
Le temps d’arriver, de s’installer et
de reconstruire de nouveau vaisseaux,
ça prend disons 1000 ans.
Et ensuite, on recommence, chaque pixel
va coloniser les pixels adjacents.
Et ainsi de suite.
Au cours du temps, voici l’évolution
qu’aurait cette civilisation.
Vous voyez les années s’écouler en haut
à gauche.
Après environ 1 million d’années c’est plié,
la galaxie entière est sous contrôle.
Donc pour des civilisations
qui sont certainement apparues
il y a plusieurs milliards d’années,
c’est largement faisable.
Rien que la Voie lactée devrait
grouiller d’extra-terrestres,
ou au moins de robots envoyés pour coloniser
progressivement la galaxie en se reproduisant.
Bon donc l’argument de la distance, il
ne marche peut-être pas tant que ça.
Voyons-en un autre: peut-être que
les bonnes planètes comme la nôtre,
susceptibles d’accueillir la vie,
eh bien ça court pas les rues.
Des exoplanètes, on en trouve
à la pelle en ce moment.
Le télescope spatial Kepler en a
détecté à lui seul près de 3000.
Et chaque fois qu'on en trouve une,
la première question
qu'on a envie de se poser, c'est:
est-ce qu'elle ressemble à la Terre?
Est-ce qu’elle pourrait abriter la vie?
Eh bien… pas évident!
Pour commencer, le Soleil n’est pas
n’importe quelle étoile.
C’est une étoile stable,
de luminosité moyenne,
dans un coin paisible de la Voile lactée.
Et de fait le Soleil est bien plus accueillant
que la majorité des étoiles de la galaxie.
Ensuite pour une planète, ressembler à la
Terre, ça veut dire déjà évidemment
être une planète rocheuse, pas gazeuse.
Ensuite il y a la question très importante
de la température.
Ce qu'on s’imagine en général, c'est
que pour que la vie se développe,
il faut de l'eau liquide, donc une température
modérée, ni trop chaud, ni trop froid.
Les limites exactes vont dépendre
de la pression
donc ça n’est pas forcément entre
0 et 100°C.
Ce qui va jouer en premier lieu, ce
sont évidemment la distance
entre la planète et son étoile,
et la puissance de cette étoile.
Et il faudrait ajouter d’autres critères
comme la présence d'effet de serre,
ou la capacité de la planète à réfléchir
le rayonnement.
Mais globalement, il n'y a pas
beaucoup de marge de manœuvre.
La zone habitable autour d’une
étoile n’est pas très large.
Par exemple si notre Terre était
située 10% plus loin,
à 165 millions de km au lieu de 150,
eh bien l’eau en surface y serait
probablement gelée.
Un critère qui découle de l’idée de
zone habitable, pour une exoplanète,
c’est également que son orbite
soit suffisamment circulaire,
pour éviter que sa distance à l’étoile
ne varie trop au cours du temps.
Donc rien que la question de la température,
ça limite beaucoup les planètes potentielles.
Ensuite pour qu'il y ait de l'eau liquide…
il faut qu'il y ait de l'eau!
Et ça n'a rien d’obligatoire.
Dans le cas de la Terre, on pense que l'eau
serait principalement d'origine externe,
c’est-à-dire qu’elle aurait
été apportée par des comètes
et des météorites aux tout début
de la formation de notre planète.
Ça n'est pas dit que les mêmes circonstances
se reproduisent systématiquement
sur une autre planète, même si elle a
la bonne température.
Il y a également un autre facteur,
c'est la rotation de la planète.
Une planète comme Mercure a toujours
la même face tournée vers le Soleil:
il fait 400°C d'un côté, -170 de l'autre:
pas très pratique pour l'apparition de la vie.
Même topo pour une planète avec un axe
de rotation très incliné comme Uranus.
Ce serait la fournaise dans l'hémisphère nord,
le désert glacé au Sud.
Non l'idéal c'est un axe de rotation
modérément incliné,
pour bien répartir les températures.
Et d'ailleurs, il y a un ingrédient
assez incroyable
qui a été très important dans le cas de la
Terre, c'est:… la Lune.
Il faut bien réaliser que la Lune est
vraiment grosse par rapport à la Terre.
On pourrait presque parler de planète double
pour désigner le couple qu’elles forment.
Or grâce à sa masse, la lune participe à la
stabilisation de l'axe de rotation de la Terre.
L’inclinaison de cet axe est aujourd'hui
d'environ 23 degrés,
c’est ce qui cause les saisons, et elle a
varié de plus ou moins quelques degrés
au cours des millions d’années
qui nous ont précédé.
Mais des calculs montrent que
sans la présence de la Lune,
l'inclinaison se baladerait en permanence
entre 0 et 85°.
Climatiquement ce serait assez instable,
et très compliqué pour l’apparition
de la vie.
Là vous allez me dire: on a qu’à se limiter
aux planètes avec un gros satellite naturel.
Sauf qu'un satellite de cette taille, c’est
en fait très certainement rarissime.
Les satellites de Mars, Jupiter ou Saturne
sont beaucoup plus petits,
comparativement à la taille de leur planète.
Eh oui si la Lune est si grosse, c’est à cause
de son origine pour le moins improbable.
On pense que le couple Terre-Lune est issu
de la collision entre deux planètes primitives.
Une sorte de proto-Terre,
et une autre planète un peu plus petite
baptisée Theia.
Et la collision aurait ensuite donné
naissance à notre planète et son satellite
Et on imagine que ça ne va pas se reproduire
pour n'importe quelle planète
Et il existe encore plein d'autres
raisons potentielles de penser
que la Terre a une chance exceptionnelle:
l’existence d'une grosse planète
comme Jupiter,
qui attire et dévie les astéroïdes ou les
comètes.
Le champ magnétique terrestre,
qui nous protège de certaines particules
que nous envoie le Soleil.
Ou encore la tectonique des plaques,
qui a facilité la disponibilité
de certains éléments chimiques.
Peut-être qu'avec toutes ces
spécificités mises bout à bout,
la Terre n'a quasiment aucun
équivalent dans la galaxie!
Et même admettons qu'il y en ait, des
planètes parfaites pour accueillir la vie.
Ça n'est pas pour autant que la vie va
y apparaitre, se développer,
et évoluer vers une civilisation intelligente.
Peut-être que, là aussi, on a bénéficié
d’un miracle?
Voici quelques unes des grandes étapes
remarquables de l'histoire de la vie.
Tout d’abord l'apparition des premières
réactions chimiques
qu'on a pu qualifier de vivantes,
évidemment.
L’émergence des premières cellules.
Plus tard, la photosynthèse.
L’apparition des cellules eucaryotes,
celles qui possèdent un noyau.
Les premiers organismes multicellulaires.
L'évolution d'espèces animales intelligentes,
et enfin l'apparition d'une espèce formant
une civilisation technologique.
Ça fait beaucoup!
Il est fort possible que une ou plusieurs
de ces étapes relèvent du miracle.
Pour commencer: l'apparition de la vie
elle-même, à partir de matière inerte.
On ne sait pas exactement à l’heure
actuelle comment ça s'est produit,
et peut-être qu'il a fallu un concours
de circonstances extraordinaires.
Ceci dit il semble que la vie soit apparue
relativement rapidement
après la formation de la Terre,
on peut donc être optimistes et se dire
que ça n’était peut-être pas une étape
si difficile.
En revanche, l’apparition de la photosynthèse
et surtout le passage des procaryotes aux
eucaryotes
sont souvent cités comme des événements
assez improbables.
On pense notamment que ces évolutions
ont pu avoir lieu
par un mécanisme appelé l'endosymbiose.
Pour faire simple, des bactéries auraient
intégré en elle d'autres bactéries,
ces dernières ayant ensuite évolué pour
donner
certains organites, comme
les mitochondries.
On imagine volontiers qu’une opération
d'endosymbiose de ce genre
ne doit réussir que de façon rarissime.
Peut-être que l’apparition des eucaryotes
n’aurait
qu’une probabilité infime de se reproduire
ailleurs.
Concernant la vie multicellulaire,
pour le coup
on a de bonnes raisons de penser que
son émergence n'a rien de miraculeux.
Elle serait en effet apparue au moins
25 fois de façon indépendante
au cours de l'histoire du vivant.
Après, peut-être que le miracle, c'est
le fait qu'une espèce intelligente
soit devenue un jour en capacité de créer
de la technologie
et de bâtir des civilisations.
Après tout on connait plein d'espèces
qu’on pourrait qualifier d’intelligentes,
comme les dauphins ou les fourmis,
mais qui n'ont a priori
aucune intention de construire des fusées
pour coloniser la galaxie.
Bref, quand on met bout à bout la rareté des
planètes favorables
et la série de miracles qu'il a fallu
pour qu'on en arrive là où on est,
peut-être bien que nous sommes la seule
espèce dans l'Univers
à se poser cette question du voyage
interstellaire.
C’est bien possible, mais rien ne
l’assure, et puis historiquement,
on sait que considérer que nous sommes
uniques et donc spéciaux dans l’Univers,
ça n’a pas été très fructueux
comme point de vue.
Donc peut-être vaut-il mieux continuer
à appliquer
ce qu'on appelle parfois
"le principe de médiocrité", celui qui dit
qu'il n'y a pas de raison de se considérer
autrement que comme quelconques.
Mais si nous sommes quelconques,
qu'il y a plein d'autres
civilisations technologiques dans l'Univers,
et que la distance n'est pas un obstacle.
On retombe sur notre problème:
où est-ce qu'elles sont?
Eh bien peut-être qu'elles s’éteignent
toutes avant de pouvoir vraiment voyager.
Quand on parle d’extinction d’une civilisation,
on peut envisager deux scénarios:
une catastrophe naturelle, ou une bonne
autodestruction.
Du côté des catastrophes naturelles,
on ne manque pas d’idées.
On sait que la Terre a déjà connu
plusieurs extinctions de masse,
on en a recensé au moins 5 dans
les 500 derniers millions d’années.
La plus connue, même si ça n’est pas été
la plus violente,
c’est évidemment celle qui s’est produite il
y a 65 millions d’années
et qui a provoqué, entre autres,
l’extinction des dinosaures.
Les chercheurs débattent encore
des causes exactes,
mais c’est probablement une combinaison
entre une activité volcanique intense
et l’impact de la météorite dont on a
retrouvé le cratère au Mexique,
et dont on estime qu’elle a délivré
une énergie
égale à plusieurs centaines de milliards
de fois la bombe de Hiroshima.
Outre les volcans et les météorites,
à la liste des catastrophes possibles
on peut aussi ajouter quelques événements
astrophysiques intenses
comme les supernovas, ou les sursauts gammas.
Eh bien peut-être que ce type d’événement
arrive sur toutes les planètes
avec une fréquence telle que jamais la vie
n’a les moyens d’atteindre
un niveau de technologie suffisant
pour vraiment débuter une colonisation
spatiale de masse.
Toutes ces causes naturelles d’extinction
sont plausibles,
mais d’un autre côté on se dit qu’il y aurait
quand même bien quelques survivants,
et qu’il leur suffisait d’une copie
de Wikipédia et du manuel des castors juniors,
pour rebâtir la civilisation en quelques
milliers d’années.
Par contre, plus efficace que
les extinctions naturelles,
ce sont peut-être les autodestructions.
Déjà l’histoire récente nous montre
qu’on est certainement passés
pas loin de l’apocalypse nucléaire,
au moins une fois ou deux.
On peut aussi évidemment imaginer que toute
civilisation technologiquement avancée
finit par s’éteindre du fait de l’épuisement
de ses ressources naturelles.
Et de façon générale, la science fiction
ne manque pas d’imagination pour envisager
des scénarios catastrophes à base d’expériences
hasardeuses sur la biotechnologie,
l’antimatière, les trous noirs, les
nanomachines qui se reproduisent.
Ou bien des IA mal dégrossies, assez
intelligentes pour nous buter,
mais pas assez pour prendre le relai
de notre glorieuse évolution.
Bref, les lois de la physique étant les mêmes
pour tout le monde,
si on peut imaginer ça pour la fin
de notre espèce,
ça doit aussi être vrai pour n’importe
quelle autre civilisation technologique.
Et peut-être que ça arrive toujours avant que
le voyage interstellaire ne devienne possible.
Pour partir sur une piste plus optimiste,
il y aussi toute une classe
de solutions au paradoxe de Fermi
qui reposent sur des explications
dites sociologiques, ou culturelles.
Peut-être qu’il existe effectivement
des civilisations avancées, stables,
et qui auraient les moyens technologiques
du voyage interstellaire,
mais qui n’en ont juste rien à faire.
Il se pourrait que pour une civilisation
avancée,
le concept de colonisation spatiale
soit tout simplement ridicule.
Ça demande beaucoup de moyens matériels,
c’est risqué,
ça n'apporte pas grand chose,
et on ne peut même pas vraiment communiquer
à cause du temps de trajet des signaux.
Franchement, quel intérêt?
Parmi les explications de la même famille,
on peut penser que toute civilisation avancée
finit par se perdre dans les paradis virtuels.
En gros il se créent des super jeux vidéo en
réalité virtuelle,
et le besoin d’explorer le monde physique
devient négligeable.
La version extrême de cet argument,
c’est que les extraterrestres ont peut-être
tous uploader leur esprit
dans des ordinateurs, et vivent exclusivement
dans leur propre simulation.
Toutes ces explications culturelles,
qui pourraient expliquer
l’absence de trace visible d’autres
civilisations,
elles ont quand même un inconvénient:
ça ne fonctionne que si elles s’appliquent à
toutes les civilisations sans exception.
Il en suffit d’une dans la galaxie qui trouve
que la colonisation c’est quand même cool,
et hop en 1 million d’années
elle va tout envahir.
A moins que… ce soit plus compliqué que ça.
Il y a une explication que j’aime bien
qui repose justement sur l’idée que
la culture, ça peut varier.
Reprenons notre animation de toute à l’heure,
où une civilisation colonise la
voie lactée de proche en proche.
Supposez maintenant que chaque fois
qu’on colonise un nouveau pixel,
comme les communications avec le pixel
d’origine sont essentiellement coupées,
il se développe une nouvelle culture.
C’est comme si chaque pixel accueillait
une nouvelle civilisation.
Imaginez que pour chaque nouvelle
civilisation,
la tentation colonisatrice ne se réalise
qu’avec une certaine probabilité: disons 42%.
On va modifier notre simulation: chaque fois
qu’un nouveau pixel est envahi,
on détermine la culture de la nouvelle
civilisation,
et elle sera expansionniste avec seulement
42% de chance.
Voici ce qu’on obtient alors.
Les civilisations qui ne sont pas
colonisatrices s’arrêtent,
et on voit qu’on arrive effectivement à une
forme de conquête progressive de la galaxie,
mais avec des gros trous, comme un gruyère.
Peut-être que tout simplement on se
trouve dans une de ces zones inexplorées.
Pour finir passons à la dernière famille
d’arguments
qui prétendent résoudre
le paradoxe de Fermi:
les explications qui disent que d’une façon
ou d’une autre,
les extraterrestres existent, ont colonisé
la galaxie.
Bref, ils sont déjà là!
[jingle]
Alors rassurez vous, je ne vais
pas vous parler de Roswell,
de la "zone 51" ou de je ne sais
quelle théorie complotiste
impliquant un gouvernement mondial
qui nous cache tout.
Non, on va essayer de regarder les choses
sous un angle rationnel.
Une hypothèse qu’on peut largement envisager,
c’est que les extraterrestres savent
pertinemment qu’on existe,
mais ils nous laissent délibérément
tranquilles, sans se montrer.
C’est une idée qu’on retrouve couramment en
science-fiction,
par exemple dans Star Trek, il y a une règle
appelée la Première Directive,
qui dit en gros qu’il ne faut pas
interférer avec les civilisations
qui ne sont pas encore suffisamment avancées.
On appelle ça parfois l’hypothèse du zoo,
encore qu’on devrait parler plutôt de
réserve naturelle protégée.
Peut-être que le système solaire
est une réserve naturelle protégée
instaurées par les civilisations
extraterrestres.
Ça vous parait peut-être inconcevable que
des civilisations avancées soient là
en train de nous regarder peinard, mais
il faut avoir les ordres de grandeur en tête.
Le ciel c’est grand, et on n’en observe
finalement pas grand chose.
Tenez par exemple, il serait parfaitement
envisageable
que l’étoile de la mort soit en orbite
dans la ceinture de Kuiper,
juste après Neptune.
Et avec nos télescopes, on n'aurait
aucune chance de la voir.
et bien planquée dans l'axe de la voie lacté,
ça serait encore pire.
Évidemment, on se dit que toute civilisation
avancée doit laisser des traces,
comme des ondes électromagnétique.
C’est d’ailleurs pour ça que le programme
SETI cherche à détecter des signaux
de ce genre.
Or jusqu’ici on a rien entendu.
Mais après tout une civilisation technologique
capable de voyage interstellaire
utilise peut-être depuis longtemps un truc
plus évolué que les ondes électromagnétiques.
Bref, rien n’exclut que l’on soit
effectivement observés
et laissés tranquilles par
les petits hommes verts.
Une variante un peu extrême de cet argument,
c’est de dire tout simplement que ce sont
eux qui nous on créés
et qu'en fait on vit dans une simulation.
Je ne sais pas du tout si on peut vraiment
parler de vie extraterrestre
Une autre possibilité, c’est que les
extraterrestres existent,
se baladent dans la galaxie,
mais n’en aient pas grand chose à faire
de nous et de notre système solaire.
Ils ont peut-être une vague idée
qu’on existe mais ils ont mieux à faire,
comme explorer les trous noirs ou exploiter
l’énergie d’étoiles
beaucoup plus lumineuse que notre
pauvre petit Soleil.
Encore une fois, arrêtons de nous prendre
pour le truc le plus intéressant de l’Univers.
Bien au total, on a vu plusieurs solutions
possibles au paradoxe Fermi.
Il en existe évidemment encore d’autres, et
peut-être que vous vous demandez:
Laquelle est la plus convaincante?
Difficile à dire, et ça pourrait aussi
très bien être un mélange de tout ça.
Peut-être que la physique rend vraiment
le voyage intergalactique trop galère,
donc qu’il faut raisonner uniquement sur la
Voie lactée.
Sur seulement quelques centaines
de milliards de planète.
Peut-être que dans celles-ci, la rareté
des planètes favorables
et la difficulté de l’apparition de la vie
font qu’il n’y a
que quelques dizaines de civilisations
intelligentes,
qui soit restent tranquilles chez elles,
soit se sont baladées mais
sans s’intéresser à nous.
Mais en conclusion, je voudrais
vous présenter la solution
que, personnellement, moi, je trouve
la plus convaincante.
La voici: les extraterrestres sont là,
partout, on n’a aucun moyen
de s’en rendre compte, et eux n’ont
même pas vu qu’on était là.
Pour comprendre cette idée, il faut
réaliser une chose.
Qu’est-ce que ce serait le niveau de technologie
d’une civilisation extraterrestre?
Reprenons notre petit diagramme sur l’histoire
de l’Univers.
Disons que nous, en tant qu’espèce, on a
100 000 ans de développement technologique.
On s’en fout de la valeur exacte.
Prenons une civilisation extraterrestre
au hasard, apparue sur une planète quelconque.
Il n’y a aucune chance qu’elle soit apparue
pile au même moment
et qu’elle ait elle-aussi environ
100 000 ans de développement technologique.
Non elle en a probablement 1 milliard,
peut-être même 4 ou 5.
Est-ce que vous arrivez à vous imaginer
une civilisation
ayant 1 milliards d’années de développement
technologique d’avance sur nous.
Me dites pas vous que vous pouvez.
On sait que la technologie progresse de
façon plutôt exponentielle.
On arrive à imaginer ce qu’elle sera
dans 10 ans.
Dans 100 ans c’est impossible.
Et dans 1000 ans c’est juste totalement
inconcevable.
Alors dans un milliard d’années?
C’est même difficile d’imaginer
des métaphores,
mais il y a probablement plus d’écart entre
la technologie aujourd’hui
et celle dans un milliard d’année,
qu’entre nous et une bactérie.
Genre c’est invraisemblable à quel point
le truc est inconcevable.
Et c’est assez logique de penser
qu’une civilisation extraterrestre
de ce niveau serait à la fois indétectable
avec notre technologie,
et qu’en plus on soit invisibles
et insignifiants à leurs yeux.
Il y a une illustration de ça
qu’on doit au physicien Michio Kaku.
C’est de dire que quand on est en voiture
sur une autoroute,
on ne remarque pas les fourmis qui sont là
sur lebord,
et elles ne nous remarquent pas non plus.
Entre nous et une civilisation extraterrestre
ayant un milliard d’années de technologie
au compteur,
c’est certainement pareil.
Donc à moins de tomber par miracle sur une
civilisation ayant juste pile poil
un niveau de développement technologique
comme le nôtre,
pas la peine de s’inquiéter
des extraterrestres.
C’est comme si on vivait dans des mondes
parallèles qui s’ignorent.
En tout cas, c’est cette explication
qui, moi, me parait la plus plausible.
Merci d’avoir suivi cette vidéo,
comme toujours je donne quelques compléments
dans le billet de blog
qui accompagne la vidéo.
Abonnez vous si ne l’êtes pas déjà
et que ce contenu vous plait.
Les actualités de la chaine, on les retrouve
sur Facebook et sur Twitter,
et nous on se revoit prochainement
pour une nouvelle vidéo.
Ciao!